Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. up for the adventure. This iconic, award-winning vehicle has been redefined with a distinctive, modern design. A reimagined exterior features compelling proportions and precise detailing.
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。准备好迎接冒险了吗？这款标志性的获奖车型经过重新定义，采用了独特而现代的设计。重新构想的外观具有引人注目的比例和精确的细节。
Built with integrity and purpose, the interior boasts robust, durable materials. Whether it's the all-terrain capability, ample cargo capacity, or innovative camera technology, the Defender 110 lets you go further and do more. And with seating for up to seven, everyone can enjoy the journey. Learn more at Land land rover.ca it was midnight when cortez gave the order to evacuate the palace it was a warm night with a fine rain in the air. A shroud of silence hung over the city. As the Spaniards moved into the alley, nobody spoke a word. Cortes had divided his company into three groups. First came the vanguard, 200 strong, led by Gonzalo de Sandoval and Diego de Odaz. This group also included Malinche and Luisa, as well as Magarino and his engineers,
内饰秉承诚信与宗旨，采用了坚固耐用的材料。无论是全地形能力、充足的载货空间，还是创新的摄像头技术，卫士 110（Defender 110）都能让您走得更远，做得更多。最多可容纳七人，让每个人都能享受旅程。欲了解更多信息，请访问 Landrover.ca。科尔特斯下令撤离宫殿时已是午夜，那是一个温暖的夜晚，空气中飘着细雨。城市笼罩在一片寂静之中。当西班牙人进入小巷时，没有人说一句话。科尔特斯将他的队伍分成了三组。第一组是先锋队，由贡萨洛·德·桑多瓦尔（Gonzalo de Sandoval）和迭戈·德·奥达斯（Diego de Odaz）率领，共 200 人。这组人还包括马林切（Malinche）和路易莎（Luisa），以及马加里诺（Magarino）和他的工程师们，
carrying their wooden bridge. Then came Cortes himself, with most of the infantry, the surviving Tlaxcalans and the gold. Finally came Alvarado and the rearguard, including most of the horsemen. Before leaving, they had muffled the horses' hooves with cloths to avoid making a sound. Quietly, they moved through the streets, heading towards the western causeway. The burned building stood silent and empty, like ghostly reminders of a vanished age. There were no signs of life. So, dramatic scenes as Cortes and the Spaniards attempt to escape Tenochtitlan, the great Mexica capital, where they've been holed up, effectively become prisoners. Moctezuma, the emperor, is dead. The man who had perhaps originally been their captor had ended up their
他们扛着木桥。接着是科尔特斯本人，带着大部分步兵、幸存的特拉斯卡拉人（Tlaxcalans）和黄金。最后是阿尔瓦拉多（Alvarado）和后卫部队，包括大部分骑兵。出发前，他们用布包裹了马蹄，以避免发出声音。他们悄无声息地穿过街道，向西部的堤道走去。被烧毁的建筑静静地矗立着，空无一人，就像一个消失时代的幽灵遗迹。没有任何生命迹象。所以，当科尔特斯和西班牙人试图逃离他们一直躲藏、实际上已成为囚徒的伟大墨西加（Mexica）首都特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）时，场面非常戏剧化。皇帝蒙特祖马（Moctezuma）已经死了。那个最初可能是他们俘虏的人，最终却成了他们的
prisoner. And the question is, will they be able to get out well so this is the night of the 30th of june and 1st of july 1520 the night known to all spanish school children and i guess mexican school children as anoche triste the sad night the night of tears now one night earlier cortez had had a council with his capt you said, Tom, yesterday we discussed how they had become prisoners within the palace in the center of Tenochtitlan, surrounded by very angry Aztecs. I think it's fair to say, to quote, horrible histories. They have no food. They have no water.
囚徒。问题是，他们能逃出去吗？好吧，这就是 1520 年 6 月 30 日到 7 月 1 日的夜晚，所有西班牙学童，我想还有墨西哥学童都知道的“悲伤之夜”（La Noche Triste），泪水之夜。就在前一天晚上，科尔特斯曾与他的队长们开过会。你说过，汤姆，昨天我们讨论了他们是如何在特诺奇蒂特兰中心的宫殿里成为囚徒的，周围都是非常愤怒的阿兹特克人。我想引用《恐怖历史》（Horrible Histories）的话来说是公平的：他们没有食物，没有水。
They've run out of gunpowder. The palace walls have been battered by their assailants. Two of those captains you mentioned, Alvarado and Ordaz, had said to Cortés, we have to escape. We have to get out. Cortés actually didn't want to. Alvarado had been banged on the head, hasn't he, by a rock. So how's he feeling? He's very cross. He had actually said to Montezuma that this was incredibly poor behavior by the Mexica in hitting him on the head with a stone. But he's recovered, has he?
他们的火药用完了。宫殿的墙壁被袭击者撞击得伤痕累累。你提到的那两位队长，阿尔瓦拉多和奥达斯，曾对科尔特斯说：“我们必须逃跑。我们必须离开。”科尔特斯其实并不想走。阿尔瓦拉多被石头砸中了脑袋，不是吗？那么他感觉如何？他非常生气。他实际上曾对蒙特祖马说，墨西加人拿石头砸他的头，这种行为极其恶劣。但他康复了吗？
Montezuma pointed out perfectly reasonably that Alvarado just killed about 500 people. Oh, you know, fair play. But Alvarado was back up and about, presumably with a bandage or something. Now, the thing is, they win the day. Cortes didn't want to leave because he said, we might lose a lot of our gold. He's obsessed with the gold. Of course he is. Yeah.
蒙特祖马非常合理地指出，阿尔瓦拉多刚刚杀死了大约 500 人。哦，你知道，这很公平。但阿尔瓦拉多又站起来活动了，大概是缠着绷带之类的。现在的问题是，他们赢得了这一天。科尔特斯不想离开，因为他说：“我们可能会损失很多黄金。”他痴迷于黄金。他当然是。是的。
But the others say, listen, we've got to go. We can't stay here any longer. No one's going to come and rescue us. There just one causeway left the western causeway and even there the aztecs have dismantled many of the bridges across the different channels the sort of canals and channels so you mentioned magarino and the wooden bridge one of his lieutenants a guy called francisco rodriguez magarino said to them why don't we knock down all the doors of the palace the internal doors and make a makeshift bridge out planks basically and we can use that to get across the canals. So that night, the 30th of June, they pack up as much of the treasure as they can.
但其他人说：“听着，我们必须走。我们不能再待在这里了。没有人会来救我们。”只剩下最后一条堤道，即西部堤道，即使在那里，阿兹特克人也拆除了跨越不同水道的许多桥梁，也就是那些运河和水道。所以你提到了马加里诺和那座木桥，他的一名副官，一个叫弗朗西斯科·罗德里格斯·马加里诺（Francisco Rodriguez Magarino）的人对他们说：“我们为什么不拆掉宫殿所有的门，那些内部的门，用木板做一个临时桥？我们可以用它来穿过运河。”所以那天晚上，6 月 30 日，他们尽可能多地打包了财宝。
They have native porters and they have mares carrying these boxes. There's a huge mob of them. I mean, there's a thousand men. They must have slaves. They must have servants with them as well who aren't mentioned in the sources. Bernal Diaz, the great chronicler, memoirist, although of course, how much is he making up? We don't know. He says, we began to move forward at about the hour of midnight. It was rather dark, a thin mist hung over the town and gentle rain was falling. So they're creeping out. Through Dominic, in your tremendous prose, A Shroud of Silence. Yes, yes. And of course, a shroud, I mean, you know, that's what you lay of the dead, isn't it?
他们有当地的搬运工，还有驮着这些箱子的母马。他们有一大群人。我的意思是，有一千人。他们一定有奴隶。他们身边一定还有来源中没有提到的仆人。伟大的编年史家、回忆录作者贝尔纳·迪亚斯（Bernal Diaz），虽然当然，他编造了多少我们不知道。他说：“我们在午夜时分开始前进。天色相当暗，一层薄雾笼罩着城镇，细雨正在落下。”所以他们正在悄悄溜走。多米尼克，用你那惊人的文笔，写道“笼罩在寂静之中”。是的，是的。当然，裹尸布，我的意思是，你知道，那是你用来覆盖死者的东西，不是吗？
Yeah, so ominous. See what you're doing there. See what you're doing there. It's actually such fine writing. And for those people who don't know, it's the latest volume of the Adventures in Time series, The Fall of the Aztecs, available now. I think you're best. That's kind of you, Tom. That's very kind of you.
是的，太不祥了。看看你在做什么。看看你在做什么。这确实是很好的写作。对于那些不知道的人，这是《时间冒险》（Adventures in Time）系列的最新一卷，《阿兹特克的陨落》（The Fall of the Aztecs），现已上市。我认为你是最棒的。你太客气了，汤姆。你太客气了。
I mean, they're all brilliant, but I think this is absolutely the best. So they make it through the streets and it's odd. Again, it's one of those odd details that if you're reading with a sceptical eye, you think, how did that happen? Why was there nobody to see them? Why were Mashika warriors not waiting, thinking that they might do just this? Possibly is it another trap? We don't know. Anyway, they go through the streets. We're now into the early hours of the morning. They're carrying planks and this makeshift bridge and whatnot. And actually, they get across the first three channels perfectly well. I mean, there's a huge column of them, must have been.
我的意思是，它们都很精彩，但我认为这一本绝对是最好的。所以他们穿过了街道，这很奇怪。同样，这是那些奇怪的细节之一，如果你带着怀疑的眼光阅读，你会想，那是怎么发生的？为什么没有人看到他们？为什么墨西加战士没有在等待，认为他们可能会这样做？可能这是另一个陷阱？我们不知道。无论如何，他们穿过了街道。我们现在进入了清晨。他们扛着木板和这座临时桥之类的东西。实际上，他们非常顺利地穿过了前三条水道。我的意思是，他们一定有一支庞大的纵队。
Very quiet. They're horseshoes, muffled, as we said, cloths. And the story is that they get to the fourth channel. And it's taken a long time. So some very, very early birds are perhaps getting up or something. And there's a local woman who has gone to get water from the lake. And she's filling her buckets. And she looks up and sees them, Tom, and screams. And at the moment that she screams, they're getting away. They're trying to escape.
非常安静。正如我们所说，他们的马蹄用布包裹着。故事是他们到达了第四条水道。这花了很多时间。所以一些非常早起的人可能正在起床之类的。有一个当地妇女去湖边取水。她正在装水桶，她抬头看到了他们，汤姆，然后尖叫起来。就在她尖叫的那一刻，他们正在逃跑。他们试图逃脱。
Suddenly, there's a great kind of banging and trumpeting from the top of one of the temple pyramids. And a priest is shouting, captains, warriors, Mexicans, our enemies are escaping. Follow them in your boats. Cut them off. Destroy them. And at that point, it all kicks off. I mean, all hell breaks loose so what follows
突然，从其中一座神庙金字塔的顶部传来了一阵巨大的敲击声和号角声。一个祭司在喊：“队长们，战士们，墨西哥人，我们的敌人正在逃跑。用你们的船追赶他们。切断他们的退路。消灭他们。”就在那一刻，一切都爆发了。我的意思是，地狱之门打开了。所以接下来
is an incredibly apocalyptic scene so it's dark the sun has not yet risen so this possibly suggests it could be a trap the speed with which the mashika fall on them also large quantities coming out in canoes canoes i mean who's who's hanging around in a canoe at that hour two o'clock in the morning and that would work best if they're right in the middle of the causeway and they've got nowhere to retreat. Of course. And also, they're all armed with spears, aren't they? Because they come canoeing up and jab up at the horses. They do. That's exactly what they do. So most of the Spaniards are on the causeway and the Aztecs pile in from all sides. In the darkness, it's just an absolute chaos of screaming
是一个极其末日的场景。天很黑，太阳还没有升起，所以这可能暗示这可能是一个陷阱。墨西加人袭击他们的速度，以及大量乘独木舟出来的人——我的意思是，谁会在凌晨两点那种时候在独木舟里闲逛？如果他们正好在堤道中间，无处可退，那效果最好。当然。而且，他们都装备着长矛，不是吗？因为他们划着独木舟上来，向马匹刺去。他们确实这样做了。所以大多数西班牙人在堤道上，阿兹特克人从四面八方涌入。在黑暗中，这简直是一片尖叫的混乱
and spears and arrows flying through the air and bloodshed. Lots of people start falling into their lake. The wooden bridge collapses under the weight of people, but also because the Mexica are stabbing it with their spears to splinter it. So that collapses and all the people on the bridge fall in. The mares carrying the treasure fall in. Some Spaniards go in after them. Cortez. Yeah. Gold. The Aztecs are piling in all around them. The air is full of blood and shrieking and shouting and total chaos. They have cannons with them that fall in. So Dominic, in this scenario, probably best to be in the vanguard, right? Absolutely, it scenario, probably best to be in the vanguard, right? Absolutely it is. And worse to be in the rear guard. Yes, yes. I mean, as we said,
和在空中飞舞的长矛与箭矢，以及流血。很多人开始掉进湖里。木桥在人的重量下坍塌了，但也因为墨西加人用长矛刺它，使其碎裂。所以桥塌了，桥上所有的人都掉进去了。驮着财宝的母马掉进去了。一些西班牙人跟着跳下去。科尔特斯。是的。黄金。阿兹特克人正从四面八方涌入。空气中充满了血腥味、尖叫声、喊叫声和彻底的混乱。他们带着的大炮也掉进去了。所以多米尼克，在这种情况下，最好是在先锋队，对吧？绝对是这样。而在后卫部队则更糟。是的，是的。我的意思是，正如我们所说，
the vanguard, Sanderbal and Ordath, they get across. Now they are taken with them. Malinche, they have taken Alvarado's slash Carlin bride, Donia Luisa. Because she is a kind of living link of the alliance, isn't she? Living symbol of it. Living link of the alliance. And the one of all those sort of brides that we know most about, that he seems to have had a genuine attachment to, or they formed a genuine attachment anyway. They've killed all their other hostages except one, and that is Montezuma's 11-year-old daughter, Tequich Pochtin, who ends up being given a Spanish name. And big spoiler alert, she ends up living with Hernan Cortes. Almost every woman in this story ends up living with Hernan Cortes at some point. And whether
先锋队，桑多瓦尔和奥达斯，他们穿过去了。现在他们带着马林切，他们带走了阿尔瓦拉多的特拉斯卡拉新娘，多尼亚·路易莎（Donia Luisa）。因为她是联盟的一种活生生的纽带，不是吗？联盟的活象征。联盟的活纽带。而且是我们所知最多的那些新娘中的一个，他似乎对她有真正的依恋，或者无论如何他们形成了真正的依恋。他们杀死了除一人之外的所有其他人质，那就是蒙特祖马 11 岁的女儿特基奇·波奇廷（Tequich Pochtin），她最终被赋予了一个西班牙名字。剧透预警，她最终和埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernan Cortes）住在一起。这个故事里的几乎每个女人最终都在某个时候和埃尔南·科尔特斯住在一起。而这
this is entirely voluntary is very dubious to say the least. So they've taken her with them. In this incredible chaotic scene, bodies are toppling into the water. The treasure is lost. The horses have fallen into the water. Bernard Diaz says, the people shouting, help, help, they're killing me. Lots of people are clambering over the bodies in their desperation to get across the channels. The whole thing is filling up with blood. And the bridge, does the bridge last?
是否完全出于自愿是非常值得怀疑的，至少可以这么说。所以他们带走了她。在这个极其混乱的场景中，尸体掉进水里。财宝丢失了。马匹掉进了水里。贝尔纳·迪亚斯说，人们喊着：“救命，救命，他们在杀我。”许多人在绝望中踩着尸体爬过水道。整个地方都充满了鲜血。那么桥呢，桥还在吗？
The bridge has been destroyed. So if you're stranded, you're stuffed? Well, you're either stuffed or you have to swim. You have to jump in and swim and hope to get across. Of course, a lot of the Spaniards can't swim. Yeah, and they've got their armour on, haven't they? Plus, the thing is filled up with the bodies of your mates. There are stories about people managing to clamber across on a kind of bridge of corpses.
桥已经被毁了。所以如果你被困住了，你就完了？好吧，你要么完了，要么必须游泳。你必须跳进去游泳，希望能够穿过去。当然，很多西班牙人不会游泳。是的，而且他们穿着盔甲，不是吗？另外，那个地方填满了你同伴的尸体。有一些关于人们设法在一种尸体桥上爬过去的故事。
Yeah. Of course, all the time, people are firing arrows at you. The canoes. Canoes charging in at you. Yeah. I mean, a lot of canoe action going on. Lots of canoe action. So it really is a scene of total apocalyptic bloodshed and chaos cortez himself gets across
是的。当然，一直有人在向你射箭。独木舟。独木舟向你冲过来。是的。我的意思是，有很多独木舟行动。有很多独木舟行动。所以这确实是一个彻底的末日流血和混乱的场景。科尔特斯本人穿过了
and he's covered in water and mud and blood and all sorts yeah he's lost all his gold he's lost all his gold he's in a terrible state he looks around him on the bank who else is there malinche has got across donia luisa has got across tech. Tequich Potsen, the 11-year-old girl, has vanished. Lordly daughter. They assume at the time, probably dead. Yeah. Cortes' servant is dead. Lots of the people he knew back on Cuba. Now, what about Alvarado? Because he's commanding the rear guard. Alvarado pitches up. Of course he pitches up. He's one of those people. He's like a cockroach. He pitches up and Cortes says to him, where's the rear guard? Where are all the rest of the men? And Alvarado says, some of them are here and the ones who aren't here, forget about them.
他浑身是水、泥和血，各种东西。是的，他失去了所有的黄金。他失去了所有的黄金。他处于一种可怕的状态。他在岸上环顾四周，还有谁在那里？马林切穿过了，多尼亚·路易莎穿过了，特基奇·波奇廷，那个 11 岁的女孩，消失了。高贵的女儿。他们当时认为，可能死了。是的。科尔特斯的仆人死了。很多他在古巴认识的人。那么阿尔瓦拉多呢？因为他在指挥后卫部队。阿尔瓦拉多出现了。他当然出现了。他是那种人。他就像一只蟑螂。他出现了，科尔特斯对他说：“后卫部队在哪里？剩下的人都在哪里？”阿尔瓦拉多说：“有些人在这里，那些不在这里的，忘了他们吧。”
Move on. Yeah. Losers. Yeah. Don't be such a bore. But that shroud of silence, Dominic. Yeah. That shroud of silence has now been draped over the corpses of many a Spaniard. Probably 600 Spaniards are dead. Right. And just to say, presumably lots of these are the guys who signed up back on the coast thinking it was going to be loads of gold and women and it'd be tremendous. Yeah. Thinking it was a walkover.
继续前进。是的。失败者。是的。别那么无聊。但那层寂静的裹尸布，多米尼克。是的。那层寂静的裹尸布现在已经覆盖在许多西班牙人的尸体上了。可能有 600 名西班牙人死亡。对。而且只是想说，大概其中许多人是当初在海岸上报名参加的人，以为会有大量的黄金和女人，那将是极好的。是的。以为这是一次轻松的胜利。
Yeah. I mean, they must have died cursing Cortez, I imagine. Yeah. I mean, they must have died cursing Cortez, I imagine. But presumably also one of the effects of this is that eyewitnesses to what's been going on, I mean, lots of them have died now. The people who came with Cortez right from the beginning, I mean, it kind of makes it easier to rewrite the story, doesn't it? It does. And this is such, it's such a good point you raised there, Tom. It really is such a good point is it oh no because i think it's i hadn't thought of saying that but it goes to the historiography and i know you like
是的。我的意思是，他们一定是在诅咒科尔特斯中死去的，我想。是的。我的意思是，他们一定是在诅咒科尔特斯中死去的，我想。但大概这也是其中一个影响，即目击者，我的意思是，他们中的许多人现在已经死了。那些从一开始就和科尔特斯一起来的人，我的意思是，这让重写故事变得更容易了，不是吗？确实。这是一个很好的观点，你提到了，汤姆。这确实是一个很好的观点。是吗？哦，不，因为我想我没想过要那样说，但这涉及到史学，我知道你喜欢
talking about historiography love it because the account that we have which is dominated by cortez is skewed by the very fact that cortez didn't die yeah i mean you've described alvarado as a cockroach i mean cortez is the cockroach to end all cockroaches. Yes, he is. It's astonishing the scrapes he gets out of. It's incredible that, a big spoiler, Hernan Cortez will die peacefully in his bed. And there just seems to be no justice or logic in that at all. Because so many of the people that he had initially left Cuba with die either now or in the next year or two. I mean, sometimes they're killed by each other later on when they fall out, or they're killed in fighting against the Aztecs or whatever. But Cortes is unusual in going all the way through and not dying. And that means that
谈论史学。我很喜欢。因为我们拥有的记录，主要是由科尔特斯主导的，被科尔特斯没有死这一事实所扭曲。是的，我的意思是，你把阿尔瓦拉多描述为蟑螂，我的意思是，科尔特斯是终极蟑螂。是的，他是。他摆脱困境的能力令人震惊。令人难以置信的是，一个大剧透，埃尔南·科尔特斯将平静地死在他的床上。这其中似乎根本没有任何正义或逻辑。因为他最初离开古巴时的许多人要么现在死了，要么在接下来的一两年里死了。我的意思是，有时他们后来在闹翻时被对方杀死，或者在与阿兹特克人的战斗中被杀，等等。但科尔特斯不同寻常，他一直坚持到底，没有死。这意味着
he can then rewrite the story with himself as the protagonist, himself as the star, the great captain, the general, the planner. Because if he had died in the Noche Triste, I mean, firstly, I imagine it's improbable that the campaign would have continued. He seems to be very much the guiding light for that. But also the story would be very different, wouldn't it? I mean, there'd be no one to make his case. He'd be cast as a kind of headstrong idiot who had ignored orders and led thousands of Spaniards to their deaths. Absolutely, he would. Because this, the Notte Trista, is an utter catastrophe. They lose all their cannons. They lose almost all of their horses. They had Tlaxcalan allies, and they're all dead. And all their gold is gone. The one thing that they had made the trip for is
他可以重写故事，把自己作为主角，把自己作为明星，伟大的队长，将军，策划者。因为如果他死在“悲伤之夜”，我的意思是，首先，我认为远征不太可能继续。他似乎非常是那场远征的指路明灯。但故事也会非常不同，不是吗？我的意思是，没有人会为他辩护。他会被塑造成一个固执己见、无视命令并导致数千名西班牙人死亡的白痴。绝对会。因为这，“悲伤之夜”，是一场彻底的灾难。他们失去了所有的大炮。他们失去了几乎所有的马匹。他们有特拉斯卡拉盟友，他们都死了。所有的黄金都没了。他们进行这次旅行的唯一目的就是
lost. And this is when Cortes writes to the king, isn't it? Yes, after this. Giving his spin about how Mo Montezuma had surrendered. I've been cheated. I've been terribly cheated because Montezuma gave us his kingdom. Right. He gave you, your majesty, the kingdom. Correct. Yes. I mean, that's the thing because he's trying to... I'm only thinking about you, your majesty. Because basically his failure is total at this point. Total. And actually it's said, he must know it at some point, it is said that afterwards, this very famous scene going to Spanish children's books, Cortes sits under this huge tree crying
丢失了。这就是科尔特斯写信给国王的时候，不是吗？是的，在这之后。讲述他关于蒙特祖马是如何投降的说法。我被骗了。我被严重欺骗了，因为蒙特祖马把他的王国给了我们。对。他把王国给了您，陛下。正确。是的。我的意思是，这就是重点，因为他试图……我只是在为您着想，陛下。因为基本上他在这一点上是彻底失败的。彻底。实际上有人说，他一定在某个时候知道，据说后来，这非常著名的场景进入了西班牙儿童读物，科尔特斯坐在那棵大树下哭泣
in floods of tears because it has all gone so horribly wrong. And yet there's still that sliver of ice. And I can still see Michael Wood telling the story in his brilliant TV series, Conquistadors. Cortes pulls himself together and says to his men, I just want to know one thing. Is Martin Lopez, who's a kind of carpenter who's built ships for him before, says, is Martin Lopez alive? Did he make it? And they say, he's been wounded, but he's still alive.
泪流满面，因为一切都变得如此糟糕。然而，仍然有一丝冰冷。我仍然可以看到迈克尔·伍德（Michael Wood）在他精彩的电视系列片《征服者》（Conquistadors）中讲述这个故事。科尔特斯振作起来，对他的手下说：“我只想知道一件事。马丁·洛佩斯（Martin Lopez）——一个以前为他造过船的木匠——他还活着吗？他成功了吗？”他们说：“他受伤了，但他还活着。”
And Cortés smiles and he says, vamos, que nada nos falta. Let us go then, for we lack nothing. Meaning, we've got all we need. Let's crack on. He's looking ahead to the climactic battle that has to come. He's looking ahead. I can believe that story, actually, because Cortés clearly,
科尔特斯笑了，他说：“Vamos, que nada nos falta。”（走吧，我们什么都不缺。）意思是，我们拥有我们需要的一切。让我们继续前进。他正在展望即将到来的决定性战斗。他正在展望。我实际上可以相信那个故事，因为科尔特斯显然，
it's one of the miraculous things about him that mean that he's not a mediocrity. He does look ahead and he is already thinking, okay, fine, that didn't go to plan. What next? But even then, they set off again. They head back. They trudge back up into the mountains. They're being harried the whole time by Mexica attacks and Mexica allies, kind of guerrilla attacks. I mean, they could have been finished off then and there, but they somehow make it back. And again, this is a timeless scene, isn't it? From colonial history that will follow. The retreat from Kabul. Yeah, absolutely. And
这是他身上奇迹般的事情之一，意味着他不是一个平庸之辈。他确实在展望未来，他已经在想，好吧，没关系，那没有按计划进行。接下来是什么？但即便如此，他们又出发了。他们往回走。他们蹒跚着回到山上。他们一直受到墨西加人的攻击和墨西加盟友的游击式袭击。我的意思是，他们本可以在那时被消灭，但他们不知何故成功回去了。这又是一个永恒的场景，不是吗？从随后的殖民历史来看。从喀布尔撤退。是的，绝对是。而且
then they make it back to Tlaxcala. Right. And so this is the key question, isn't it? What are the Tlaxcalans going to do? Are they going to wash their hands or are they going to stick with the alliance? So Tom, I've written in my notes in capital letters. Well, you can read it. Yes. A key moment in Mexican, even world history. What will the Tlaxcalans do? So Dominic, what will the Tlaxcalans do? So the Tlaxcalans could finish them off then and there. They're down to hundreds.
然后他们回到了特拉斯卡拉。对。所以这是关键问题，不是吗？特拉斯卡拉人会怎么做？他们会洗手不干，还是会坚持联盟？所以汤姆，我在我的笔记里用大写字母写了。好吧，你可以读出来。是的。墨西哥乃至世界历史的关键时刻。特拉斯卡拉人会怎么做？所以多米尼克，特拉斯卡拉人会怎么做？所以特拉斯卡拉人本可以在那时就消灭他们。他们只剩下几百人了。
They're absolutely bedraggled. They've lost the cannons, the horses. They're very miserable. Most of the Spaniards, I mean, they must be asking questions about Cortes. And what is more, Montezuma has now got a successor called Cuitlahuec. And he sends messages to Tlaxcala. We may have differed and quarreled in the past, but now one bond unites us all to destroy these flipping Spaniards.
他们绝对是衣衫褴褛。他们失去了大炮、马匹。他们非常悲惨。大多数西班牙人，我的意思是，他们一定在质疑科尔特斯。而且更重要的是，蒙特祖马现在有了一个继任者，叫奎特拉瓦克（Cuitlahuec）。他向特拉斯卡拉发送了信息：“我们过去可能存在分歧和争吵，但现在一个纽带将我们所有人团结在一起，消灭这些该死的西班牙人。”
And he says to the Tlaxcalans, come on, let's have an eternal alliance, bury the hatchet, kill the Spaniards. And some of the Tlaxcalans say, yeah, yeah, let's do it. This is a good idea. There's a guy who's always been suspicious of them called Chico Tencatl the Younger, because there's Chico Tencatl the Older. Yeah, I guess that. He has always been suspicious of the Spaniards. And he says, Tom, quite rightly, they are a plague of ravenous grasshoppers. They will never stop. Let's end this now. But there is another way of spinning that, isn't there? And that perspective is spun by Donna Luisa, the Tlaxcalan princess,
他对特拉斯卡拉人说：“来吧，让我们建立一个永恒的联盟，化干戈为玉帛，杀死西班牙人。”一些特拉斯卡拉人说：“是的，是的，让我们这样做。这是一个好主意。”有一个人一直怀疑他们，叫小奇科滕卡特尔（Chico Tencatl the Younger），因为有老奇科滕卡特尔。是的，我猜到了。他一直怀疑西班牙人。他说，汤姆，说得很对：“他们是一场贪婪的蝗虫瘟疫。他们永远不会停止。让我们现在结束这一切。”但还有另一种说法，不是吗？那个观点是由特拉斯卡拉公主多尼亚·路易莎提出的，
who's Marin Alvarado. Because she makes exactly the point that they are indeed like grasshoppers and plagues of them are going to be coming. There is no stopping them. So this is what I guess would be Moctezuma's position as well, that it doesn't matter if you get rid of Cortes, it doesn't matter if you get rid of the Spaniards who are in Tlaxcala now, more will be coming. And therefore you want to be on the side of this plague of grasshoppers. Which you could argue is true. Well, it is absolutely true. I mean, it is true. Of course, if they had killed Cortes, I think it's reasonable to say European colonizers would
她是马林·阿尔瓦拉多的妻子。因为她提出了完全相同的观点，即他们确实像蝗虫，而且瘟疫将会到来。没有办法阻止他们。所以我想这也是蒙特祖马的立场，即如果你摆脱了科尔特斯并不重要，如果你摆脱了现在在特拉斯卡拉的西班牙人也不重要，更多的人将会到来。因此，你想站在这些蝗虫瘟疫的一边。你可以说这是真的。好吧，这绝对是真的。我的意思是，这是真的。当然，如果他们杀死了科尔特斯，我认为可以说欧洲殖民者最终会
have arrived eventually. Now, maybe the Spanish would have been slower to arrive. Maybe they'd have been warned off and they'd have stayed away for 10 years or so, but maybe not. Maybe it would just have been a year or two. Somebody else, Velazquez, Diego Colon, whoever. There's gold, isn't there, Dominic? There's gold. Yeah. I mean, the gold is already back in, it's been seen in Europe. Yes, exactly. So there's no way that they wouldn't be coming. So Chico Tencatl's father says to his son, no, this is a historic opportunity, but the opportunity is to destroy the Mexica, not the Spaniards. We use the Spaniards.
最终到达。现在，也许西班牙人到达得会慢一些。也许他们会被警告离开，他们会远离十年左右，但也可能不会。也许只是一两年。其他人，贝拉斯克斯（Velazquez）、迭戈·科隆（Diego Colon），无论谁。有黄金，不是吗，多米尼克？有黄金。是的。我的意思是，黄金已经在欧洲被看到了。是的，完全正确。所以他们不可能不来。所以奇科滕卡特尔的父亲对他的儿子说：“不，这是一个历史性的机会，但机会是消灭墨西加人，而不是西班牙人。我们利用西班牙人。”
So they take the Spaniards in, they bandage their wounds, they feed them. Cortes has two fingers amputated, doesn't he? He does, exactly. The Spaniards are in a terrible condition. Malinche, and as you say, Luisa, I think they are absolutely central figures in this, almost certainly doing most of the negotiating. Some of Cortes' men, I think at this point, we do get hints of discontent. Some of Cortes' men are not happy with this point, we do get hints of discontent. Some of Cortez's men are not happy with this arrangement. And they say to Cortez, please now, enough. This has been a disaster. Let's go home. Our heads are broken. Our bodies are rotting. We're covered with wounds
所以他们收留了西班牙人，给他们包扎伤口，给他们食物。科尔特斯被截去了两根手指，不是吗？他确实是，完全正确。西班牙人的状况很糟糕。马林切，正如你所说，路易莎，我认为她们是这其中的绝对核心人物，几乎可以肯定她们在进行大部分谈判。科尔特斯的一些手下，我想在这一点上，我们确实得到了不满的暗示。科尔特斯的一些手下对这一点不满意，我们确实得到了不满的暗示。科尔特斯的一些手下对这种安排不满意。他们对科尔特斯说：“求你了，够了。这是一场灾难。让我们回家吧。我们的头破了。我们的身体在腐烂。我们浑身是伤
and sores. We're in a strange land. We're sick and surrounded by enemies. I mean, this is very Alexander the Great in India, Tom, the sort of mutiny of the men who say, God almighty, can you not call a halt now? And Cortes, very Alexander the Great style, says no. And he is given by the sources this rousing speech. Every nation which ruled the world lost one or two battles. Which great captain never lost a battle? We are Christians. We should trust to God. He will never let us be defeated. And cliche alert, fortune favors the brave. And amazingly, he obviously had let us be defeated. And cliche alert, fortune favours the brave. And amazingly, he obviously had the gift of the gab, Cortes. He was good at persuading people.
和疮。我们在一个陌生的土地上。我们生病了，被敌人包围。我的意思是，这非常像亚历山大大帝在印度，汤姆，那种士兵的兵变，他们说：“上帝啊，你现在不能叫停吗？”而科尔特斯，非常有亚历山大大帝的风格，说不。来源给了他这段激动人心的演讲：“每一个统治世界的国家都输掉了一两场战斗。哪个伟大的队长从未输过一场战斗？我们是基督徒。我们应该相信上帝。他永远不会让我们被击败。”还有陈词滥调警报，幸运眷顾勇者。令人惊讶的是，他显然让让我们被击败。还有陈词滥调警报，幸运眷顾勇者。令人惊讶的是，他显然有
There's no revolt against him from his own men. Yeah. So he can appeal to glory, but presumably he's also saying that city is absolutely stuffed with wealth. We can have it. I mean, that wouldn't be in the oratory, but that must be part of what he was saying as well. But I think what's a puzzle at this point, or what remains murky, is this renewed alliance with the Tlaxcalans. How much is this the Tlaxcalans agreeing to help the Spaniards, or is the boot very much on the other foot now? Well, that depends on your perspective, doesn't it? Because most Tlaxcalans presumably are not aware of the resources that the Spanish ultimately can command. So they're looking at the ragged survivors of the Noche Triste and presumably thinking, well, these are people that we are employing. They are entirely dependent on us.
口才，科尔特斯。他很擅长说服别人。他自己的手下没有反抗他。是的。所以他可以诉诸荣耀，但大概他也在说那座城市绝对充满了财富。我们可以拥有它。我的意思是，那不会在演讲中，但那一定也是他所说的一部分。但我认为在这一点上令人困惑的是，或者仍然模糊的是，这种与特拉斯卡拉人的重新结盟。这在多大程度上是特拉斯卡拉人同意帮助西班牙人，还是现在的情况完全反过来了？好吧，这取决于你的视角，不是吗？因为大多数特拉斯卡拉人大概不知道西班牙人最终能调动的资源。所以他们看着“悲伤之夜”的衣衫褴褛的幸存者，大概在想，好吧，这些人是我们雇佣的。他们完全依赖我们。
Yes. But if you're Don Luisa, or indeed Cortez, you'll be thinking, we just need to maintain this alliance a bit longer. And then in time, we will have the whip hand. We'll be in we just need to maintain this alliance a bit longer and then in time we will have the whip hand we'll be in the driving seat yeah and actually they'll get the whip hand much more quickly and smoothly than they think because of the secret biological weapon that is about to arrive yeah no spoilers yet but i mean the thing is that in essence for the trash carlins absolutely this seems like a war between them and the mexica it It does. And so it is in terms of numbers. And so it is in terms of Cortes' ability to influence it, presumably, because without numbers, you don't have influence. But in the long run,
是的。但如果你是多尼亚·路易莎，或者确实是科尔特斯，你会想，我们只需要再维持这个联盟一段时间。然后随着时间的推移，我们将掌握主动权。我们将处于我们只需要再维持这个联盟一段时间，然后随着时间的推移，我们将掌握主动权，我们将处于驾驶座上。是的，实际上他们会比他们想象的更快、更顺利地掌握主动权，因为即将到来的秘密生物武器。是的，还没有剧透，但我的意思是，本质上，对于特拉斯卡拉人来说，这绝对看起来像是他们和墨西加人之间的战争。确实。就人数而言，确实如此。就科尔特斯影响它的能力而言，确实如此，因为没有人数，你就没有影响力。但从长远来看，
it's Cortes who has a better understanding of the geopolitics of it, because no one in Mexico has any idea about really what lies beyond the sea, whereas Cortes completely does. Yeah, I think that's fair. It's funny because we advertised that we were doing this on Twitter and I read the responses and some people said, you know, whatever you think of it, it is an amazing adventure story and all this.
是科尔特斯对地缘政治有更好的理解，因为墨西哥没有人真正知道海那边是什么，而科尔特斯完全知道。是的，我认为这很公平。很有趣，因为我们在推特上宣传我们要这样做，我读了回复，有些人说，无论你怎么想，这都是一个了不起的冒险故事等等。
And there has been an element of the adventure story as gory and as dark as it's been. But from this point, it stops being an adventure story and actually becomes a story of an exceedingly brutal war, terror and starvation and attrition.
而且确实有一个冒险故事的元素，尽管它很血腥和黑暗。但从这一点开始，它就不再是一个冒险故事，实际上变成了一个极其残酷的战争、恐怖、饥饿和消耗的故事。
And again, looking forward to the colonial wars that will follow. Yeah, it does anticipate that. The historian that we've mentioned most, Matthew Restle, is brilliant on this. And he says, we should think of this as what it is, which is an incredibly violent, bloody war in which there's an awful lot of violence against civilians. There is rape and plunder on a massive scale. Why are the conquistadors so violent? There's an argument that it's because they have been desensitized to violence and they seek revenge after what they have already suffered. But it also makes strategic sense, doesn't it? It does to intimidate. And it also reproduces the violence that they have already
而且再次展望随后的殖民战争。是的，它确实预示了这一点。我们提到最多的历史学家马修·雷斯特尔（Matthew Restall）对此非常精辟。他说，我们应该把它看作它本来面目，这是一场极其暴力、血腥的战争，其中有大量针对平民的暴力。有大规模的强奸和掠夺。为什么征服者如此暴力？有一种观点认为，这是因为他们对暴力变得麻木，并且在遭受了已经遭受的痛苦后寻求报复。但这在战略上也说得通，不是吗？确实是为了恐吓。而且它也复制了他们已经在
done in Hispaniola and on Cuba. This is why we dwelt so much on Cortes in the Caribbean. And now they're exporting that violence onto the mainland and turning it, with the Tlaxcalans' consent, against the cities that side with Mexica rather than the Tlaxcalans. But it's slightly different, well, I mean, very different to Hispaniola and Cuba to the extent that on those islands, the Spanish have overwhelming military superiority because there's no one strong enough to oppose them, either in terms of numbers or in military ability. In Mexico, it's slightly different. But Cortes obviously understands that the only way that he and the Tlaxcalans can secure victory is if the Spanish continue to be seen as, by miles, the most
在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴所做的事情。这就是为什么我们如此关注加勒比地区的科尔特斯。现在他们正在将那种暴力输出到大陆，并在特拉斯卡拉人的同意下，将其转向那些站在墨西加人一边而不是特拉斯卡拉人一边的城市。但这与伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴略有不同，我的意思是，非常不同，因为在那些岛屿上，西班牙人拥有压倒性的军事优势，因为没有人强大到足以反对他们，无论是在人数还是军事能力方面。在墨西哥，情况略有不同。但科尔特斯显然明白，他和特拉斯卡拉人能够确保胜利的唯一途径是，如果西班牙人继续被视为，遥遥领先，最
lethal fighting force in Mexico. Because if they don't have that aura of terror, then they're nothing. And I mean, the issue of, you know, are they just mercenaries being employed by the Tlaxcalans? The more brutal they are, the less that is a risk that they have to run, because instead they will come to be seen as, by miles, the most frightening figures in the kind of the terrible game that is now risk that they have to run because instead they will come to be seen as, by miles, the most frightening figures in the kind of the terrible game that is now being played out. Don't you think? Yes, I absolutely think. I agree with you, Tom.
致命的战斗力量在墨西哥。因为如果他们没有那种恐怖的光环，那么他们就什么都不是。我的意思是，关于“他们只是特拉斯卡拉人雇佣的雇佣兵吗？”的问题，他们越残暴，他们必须承担的风险就越小，因为相反，他们将被视为，遥遥领先，在某种现在正在上演的恐怖游戏中，最可怕的人物。风险他们必须承担，因为相反，他们将被视为，遥遥领先，在某种现在正在上演的恐怖游戏中，最可怕的人物。你不觉得吗？是的，我绝对认为。我同意你的观点，汤姆。
It's a key strategic aim. It's a strategy of terror from the very beginning. So let's take a break and we will come back and we will talk about how the war begins, what's been happening in Tenochtitlan, and we will also talk about an entirely new dimension to this story. Biological. Which is the biological dimension. So we'll come back after the break. Okay, see you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是一个关键的战略目标。从一开始就是一种恐怖战略。所以让我们休息一下，回来后我们将谈论战争是如何开始的，特诺奇蒂特兰发生了什么，我们还将谈论这个故事的一个全新的维度。生物学。也就是生物学维度。所以休息后我们回来。好的，到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And as we were saying before the break, the story, which has been kind of dark pretty much from the beginning, now becomes very somber, very bloody. I mean, one of the great tragic narratives in world history, really. Man's humanity to man, Dominic. Oh, Tom, that's very profound. But also, as we said, there is a new dimension, which is the eruption across Mexico of a terrible new disease. And I think we should look at that first.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》。正如我们在休息前所说，这个故事，从一开始就相当黑暗，现在变得非常阴沉、非常血腥。我的意思是，确实是世界历史上最伟大的悲剧叙事之一。人类对人类的仁慈，多米尼克。哦，汤姆，那太深刻了。但正如我们所说，还有一个新的维度，那就是一种可怕的新疾病在墨西哥的爆发。我认为我们应该先看看那个。
Okay. If you want to look at that first. So this is the arrival in Mexico, in Tenochtitlan, of smallpox. So smallpox had already been known in the Caribbean. Smallpox, of course, was everywhere in Europe. So most of the Spaniards will have come into contact with it, although no people have come into contact with it. Many of them will have had smallpox scars. When Columbus and the first explorers and so on, when they arrived in Hispaniola, they brought smallpox with them.
好的。如果你想先看那个。所以这就是天花到达墨西哥，到达特诺奇蒂特兰。所以天花在加勒比地区已经为人所知。天花，当然，在欧洲到处都是。所以大多数西班牙人都会接触过它，尽管没有人接触过它。他们中的许多人会有天花疤痕。当哥伦布和第一批探险家等等到达伊斯帕尼奥拉岛时，他们带来了天花。
It swept through the Caribbean and effectively, to be very simplistic, it wiped out, in the long run virtually the entire Taino population. And this is why it has, again, a kind of seismic impact because the Spaniards still need labor and so they start looking to Africa for slaves. Exactly. They'd already used African slaves in the Canary Islands and the plantations there. Now they start to bring African slaves, which wasn't their original plan at all, but they
它席卷了加勒比地区，实际上，简单地说，从长远来看，它几乎消灭了整个泰诺（Taino）人口。这就是为什么它再次产生了一种地震般的影响，因为西班牙人仍然需要劳动力，所以他们开始向非洲寻找奴隶。完全正确。他们已经在加那利群岛和那里的种植园使用了非洲奴隶。现在他们开始引入非洲奴隶，这根本不是他们最初的计划，但他们
start to bring them to Hispaniola and Cuba and Jamaica and so on, because they've run out of indigenous workers. They haven't deliberately killed that workforce, by the way. So some people argue about genocide. They didn't mean to kill them. They wanted to keep them alive. To work in their minds. To work in their minds, exactly.
开始把他们带到伊斯帕尼奥拉岛、古巴和牙买加等地，因为他们的土著工人用完了。顺便说一句，他们并没有故意杀死那些劳动力。所以有些人争论种族灭绝。他们并不是想杀死他们。他们想让他们活着。在他们的矿井里工作。在他们的矿井里工作，完全正确。
Smallpox probably arrived in Mexico with Narbaez, not with Cortez, because there's no hint of it during cortez's first journey because basically all you need is a little scab on a cloak or something and that's enough you just need one person one person there's a story people have kind of fingered a culprit an african porter called francisco aguia but who knows if that's true or not or whether it's actually i mean it's very convenient they blame an african porter rather than a spaniard what's not in doubt though, is that the people of Mexico have no immunity to smallpox at all. So once it's arrived in the Abayas party, it spreads it on the coast, village after village. There are stories of villages deserted, of kind of jackals
天花可能随纳尔瓦埃斯（Narbaez）到达墨西哥，而不是随科尔特斯，因为在科尔特斯的第一次旅程中没有任何迹象，因为基本上你只需要斗篷上的一点痂之类的东西，这就足够了，你只需要一个人，一个人。有一个故事，人们指认了一个罪魁祸首，一个叫弗朗西斯科·阿吉亚（Francisco Aguia）的非洲搬运工，但谁知道那是真的还是假的，或者它实际上是——我的意思是，这非常方便，他们责怪一个非洲搬运工而不是西班牙人。不过，毫无疑问的是，墨西哥人民对天花根本没有任何免疫力。所以一旦它到达阿巴亚斯（Abayas）派对，它就在海岸上传播，一个村庄接一个村庄。有关于村庄荒废的故事，关于豺狼
and vultures feasting on the remains of the people in these towns where literally everybody has died. As one chronicler puts it, everything fell apart and it falls apart because these are communities, as in Europe, that depend on the harvest, that depend on there being a regular workforce. And if there's no one to sow and to reap and to grind, you've got no food. So people start to starve on top of that. People are starving on the coast. So by the way, when more Spaniards arrive, they find the coast deserted, the people weak and desperate, easy pickings. No one to stop them arriving and more Spaniards arrive by sea. Meanwhile, it's heading inland. By late September, smallpox has arrived in Tlaxcala, where it kills about a third of the population probably.
和秃鹫在这些城镇的遗骸上大快朵颐，那里几乎每个人都死了。正如一位编年史家所说，一切都分崩离析，它分崩离析是因为这些社区，像在欧洲一样，依赖于收成，依赖于有固定的劳动力。如果没有人播种、收割和研磨，你就没有食物。所以人们开始在饥饿之上挨饿。人们在海岸上挨饿。所以顺便说一句，当更多的西班牙人到达时，他们发现海岸荒无人烟，人们虚弱而绝望，容易成为猎物。没有人阻止他们到达，更多的西班牙人通过海路到达。与此同时，它正在向内陆蔓延。到 9 月下旬，天花到达了特拉斯卡拉，在那里它可能杀死了大约三分之一的人口。
And so that must rebalance then the relationship between Cortez and the Tlaxcala. Exactly. Definitely, Tom. Definitely. And then it starts to move, of course, it is carried further west into the Valley of Mexico, across the lake and into Tenochtitlan. So in Tenochtitlan itself, what has happened after the Noche Triste? We don't really know what the Mexica are thinking. Well, they must be thinking, ah, God, they got away. But some of them maybe think we've taught them a lesson they won't be back some of them may fear they will be back i mean who knows i think
所以这必须重新平衡科尔特斯和特拉斯卡拉人之间的关系。完全正确，汤姆。完全正确。然后它开始移动，当然，它被带到更西边的墨西哥谷，穿过湖泊进入特诺奇蒂特兰。所以在特诺奇蒂特兰本身，“悲伤之夜”之后发生了什么？我们真的不知道墨西加人在想什么。好吧，他们一定在想：“啊，上帝，他们逃走了。”但有些人可能认为我们给他们上了一课，他们不会再回来了；有些人可能担心他们会回来。我的意思是，谁知道呢，我想
they must be thinking we've goofed do you think so the whole point was to wipe them out if they escape you know they know how dangerous they are and don't forget they kill two-thirds of them sure but i think that anyone who's seen what the Spaniards are capable of will know that it's not good for them still to be out there. Which is presumably why Kuitlahuak, who is the new emperor, who is Montezuma's brother, who has taken over, why he sent a message to Tlaxcala saying, let's team up and get rid of them. However, Kuitlahuak, about whom we know almost nothing, because he lasted about 80 days as
他们一定在想我们搞砸了，你觉得呢？重点本来是把他们彻底消灭，如果让他们逃了，你知道他们有多危险，别忘了他们杀了三分之二的人。确实，但我认为任何见过西班牙人手段的人，都会明白让他们继续逍遥法外绝非好事。这大概就是为什么新皇帝奎特拉瓦克（蒙特祖马的兄弟，刚继位）会向特拉斯卡拉人传话，提议联手除掉他们。然而，关于奎特拉瓦克，我们几乎一无所知，因为他只当了大约80天的
emperor, because he gets smallpox. Smallpox, of course, doesn't discriminate between rich and poor. We have Nahuatl accounts of sores breaking out on people's heads, people lying in their beds as if they were dead, unable even to lift their heads. When they moved at all, they screamed in pain. Many died from the plague, but others died from hunger. They were too weak to look for food while everybody else was too ill to care for them. So they starved to death where they lay. I mean, it's like if Europe, while it was being hit by the Black Death, suddenly got
皇帝，因为他感染了天花。当然，天花是不分贫富的。我们有纳瓦特尔语的记载，描述人们头上长满疮口，躺在床上像死了一样，连头都抬不起来。他们稍微一动就会痛得尖叫。许多人死于瘟疫，但也有人死于饥饿。他们虚弱得无法寻找食物，而其他人也都病得无法照顾他们。于是他们就这样躺着饿死了。我的意思是，这就像欧洲在遭受黑死病袭击时，突然被
invaded by, I don't know, the Chinese. Yeah, that's exactly it, isn't it, Tom? The effect on Mexica society, I mean, the trauma, the arrival of the Spaniards, the death of Montezuma, the death of his brother, who's just taken over as emperor, the spread of this plague. I mean, they must be in shock. And actually, they're fortunate in some ways that the next emperor, who is Montezuma's cousin, the next guy to be chosen is called Cuauhtémoc. So this is the guy that we mentioned in the previous episode as a possible culprit in
我不知道，被中国人入侵了一样。是的，正是如此，对吧，汤姆？这对墨西加社会的影响，我是说，那种创伤，西班牙人的到来，蒙特祖马的死，他刚继位为皇帝的兄弟的死，以及这场瘟疫的蔓延。我的意思是，他们一定处于震惊之中。事实上，在某些方面他们很幸运，因为下一任皇帝，也就是蒙特祖马的堂兄弟，被选中的下一个人叫库奥特莫克。这就是我们在上一集提到的，可能是
the killing of Montezuma. I mean, almost certainly not, but... He's a Spaniard skeptic, I think it's fair to say, Tom. He's always been very suspicious of them. He is clearly a very formidable person. On his first day as emperor, he rounds up six of Moctezuma's sons and he has them executed.
杀害蒙特祖马的罪魁祸首。我的意思是，几乎肯定不是他，但是……我认为公平地说，他是一个西班牙怀疑论者，汤姆。他一直对他们非常警惕。他显然是一个非常可怕的人。在他当皇帝的第一天，他就把蒙特祖马的六个儿子抓起来处决了。
Very kind of Ottoman behavior, isn't it, Tom? It gets rid of all the competition. I mean, it's not just competition also, Dave. It's the kind of the doves. So his name actually means falling eagle, doesn't it? Yes. He's very much a hawk, one might say. And Montezuma's sons were much more dovish in their attitude towards the Spaniards. So by getting rid of them, he's not just getting rid of rivals,
非常有奥斯曼式的作风，不是吗，汤姆？这除掉了所有的竞争对手。我的意思是，戴夫，这不仅仅是竞争。这是一种鸽派的终结。所以他的名字实际上意味着“坠落的鹰”，对吧？是的。人们可能会说，他是一个彻头彻尾的鹰派。而蒙特祖马的儿子们对西班牙人的态度要温和得多。所以通过除掉他们，他不仅是在除掉竞争对手，
he's also getting rid of political opposition. Of appeasers. Of appeasers, yes. And then he marries Montezuma's daughter, Tocquech Pozzin, so the the hostage, who looked like she might have died in the Night of Tears. Actually, she didn't die. She was rescued from the lake by Meshika, recognized, taken back to the court, and Quauhtemoc marries her. So that's a way of uniting the various branches of the family. It's very Henry Tudor after the Battle of Bosworth, isn't it? Yeah. So he's in charge, and he seems to be an impressive guy, actually. There's no reason to doubt that he's quite a formidable person. However, not only is he facing the smallpox, he's also facing a campaign the like of which the Mexica have never seen before, because the conquistadors are determined to wage a European-style war. And Cortes' strategy is very clever. So you mentioned Terra, Tom. The first target is a hill town called Tepeaca, and that commands the trade route from the Valley of Mexico to the
他也是在除掉政治反对派。除掉绥靖者。是的，绥靖者。然后他娶了蒙特祖马的女儿托克切·波津，也就是那个在“悲伤之夜”中看起来可能已经死掉的人质。实际上，她没有死。她被墨西加人从湖中救起，被认出来后带回了宫廷，库奥特莫克娶了她。所以这是一种团结家族各支系的方式。这非常像博斯沃思战役后的亨利·都铎，不是吗？是的。所以他掌权了，而且他看起来确实是个令人印象深刻的人。没有理由怀疑他是一个相当可怕的人。然而，他不仅面临天花，还面临着墨西加人从未见过的战役，因为征服者们决心发动一场欧洲式的战争。科尔特斯的策略非常聪明。你提到了特拉，汤姆。第一个目标是一个叫特佩亚卡的山城，它控制着从墨西哥谷到
coast. Because, Dominic, the size of the city means that it is dependent on imports. Yeah. Otherwise it's going to starve. It's always been unusual, actually, to Nostitlan, because it doesn't have lots of farmlands of its own. So they do have these floating gardens, but it's in a lake. So they've always depended on tribute payments from other places. And actually, one argument for the rise of the Aztecs is that because they didn't have farmlands, they didn't have to spend lots of time faffing around with the harvest. No, like the Spartans.
海岸的贸易路线。因为，多米尼克，这座城市的大小意味着它依赖进口。是的。否则它就会饿死。实际上，特诺奇蒂特兰一直很不寻常，因为它自己没有大量的农田。所以他们确实有那些浮动花园，但它是在湖里。所以他们一直依赖其他地方的贡品。事实上，关于阿兹特克人崛起的一个论点是，因为他们没有农田，他们不必花大量时间在收成上瞎忙。不，就像斯巴达人一样。
Yeah, they were freer to go off and fight people. Well, Tepeaca commands this really important trade route. Cortes hits that first, but he hits it in an absolutely ruthless, gruesome way. You astound me. All the women and children are rounded up and they have the letter G stamped on their cheeks with a red-hot brand, meaning war, G for getter, and they are sold as slaves. The surviving men are dragged back to Tlaxcala to be sacrificed. And the story goes that others are torn apart by dogs. And there are even rumors that they are chopped up in butcher
是的，他们更自由地去打仗。嗯，特佩亚卡控制着这条非常重要的贸易路线。科尔特斯首先攻击那里，但他以一种绝对无情、可怕的方式进行攻击。你让我震惊了。所有的妇女和儿童都被抓起来，他们的脸颊上被烙上了红热的字母G，意思是战争，G代表“getter”（掠夺者），然后他们被当作奴隶卖掉。幸存的男人被拖回特拉斯卡拉作为祭品。故事说，其他人被狗撕碎了。甚至有传言说他们被切碎在屠夫
shops before being feasted on by the Tlaxcalans in the victory banquet. Now, of course, some of these stories may be wildly exaggerated or completely untrue. But it doesn't redound to the Spanish credit, does it? No, it doesn't. You know, that their allies are doing this. Cortes would say, you know what Cortes would say if he came as an unexpected guest on the rest of his history? He would say, listen, mate, I wasn't playing badminton on a Sunday afternoon. Yeah, right. But I mean, he'd be, you know, doing the slaughter. That's what you have to do. I mean, that's the way it is. But sacrificing
店里，然后在胜利宴会上被特拉斯卡拉人吃掉。当然，其中一些故事可能被极度夸大或完全不真实。但这并不能为西班牙人增光，对吧？不，不能。你知道，他们的盟友在做这些事。如果科尔特斯作为意想不到的客人出现在他余下的历史中，你知道科尔特斯会说什么吗？他会说，听着，伙计，我可不是在周日下午打羽毛球。是的，没错。但我的意思是，他会说，你知道，在进行屠杀。这就是你必须做的。我的意思是，事实就是这样。但是把
people to demons and eating them in victory feasts, no Christian is going to boast about doing that or even admit that he's been complicit in it. So where are those stories coming from? That's a good question, actually, Tom. Where are those stories coming from? Some of those stories are from indigenous sources. So it could be Mexica anti-clashcala propaganda. Of course. I mean, I think there are hints of these stories in some of the Spanish accounts, actually. The Spanish accounts don't really stint on the brutality. No, but I'm just saying that there's a qualitative difference between the kind of brutality that you'd wage in a European war and human sacrifice and cannibalism.
人献祭给恶魔并在胜利宴会上吃掉他们，没有基督徒会吹嘘自己做了这种事，甚至承认自己参与其中。那么这些故事是从哪里来的呢？这确实是个好问题，汤姆。这些故事是从哪里来的？其中一些故事来自土著来源。所以这可能是墨西加人针对特拉斯卡拉人的宣传。当然。我的意思是，我认为在一些西班牙人的记载中确实有这些故事的暗示。西班牙人的记载并没有掩盖残酷性。不，但我只是说，你在欧洲战争中发动的残酷行为与人祭和食人行为之间存在质的区别。
There is, I suppose. I mean, it's a fine distinction though, isn't it, Tom? No, no. It's all right to massacre loads of people, but not to eat them? No, absolutely not. I mean, you know, in the European context, killing people in battle is one thing. Eating them and sacrificing them to demons
我想是有的。但这是一个微妙的区别，不是吗，汤姆？不，不。屠杀一大群人是可以的，但吃掉他们就不行？不，绝对不行。我的意思是，你知道，在欧洲背景下，在战斗中杀人是一回事。吃掉他们并把他们献祭给恶魔
is unacceptable. Crossing a line, Dominic. Okay. That's where you and I would just have to disagree, Tom. Because I think... You know, I'm not saying that as a kind of moralist
是不可接受的。越界了，多米尼克。好吧。这就是你和我必须持不同意见的地方，汤姆。因为我认为……你知道，我并不是以一种道德主义者
or a philosopher. As a wokist. No, I'm saying that in the context of Christian culture... Yeah, of course. I know what you're saying. Sacrificing people to demons... I know what you're saying. Sacrificing people to demons.
或哲学家的身份在说。以一个“觉醒者”（wokist）的身份。不，我是说在基督教文化的背景下……是的，当然。我知道你在说什么。把人献祭给恶魔……我知道你在说什么。把人献祭给恶魔。
I know what you're saying. Well, stop. You're saying, how does Cortez square that? I'm not even saying that because Cortez has to lump it because he knows he has to deal with his allies. I'm just saying that it's not beyond the bounds of possibility that those things actually happened because the Christians have no stake in propagating stories like that. Oh, I agree with you completely, by the way.
我知道你在说什么。好吧，停下。你是说，科尔特斯怎么调和这一点？我甚至不是在说那个，因为科尔特斯必须忍受，因为他知道他必须处理他的盟友。我只是说，这些事情确实发生的可能性并非不存在，因为基督徒没有动机去传播这样的故事。哦，我完全同意你的观点，顺便说一句。
I totally agree with you. That's all I'm saying. In Cortez's letters and so on, he downplays the involvement of the Tlaxcala. Yeah, he doesn't want to mention that. So not only Tlaxcala, but later on, they'll have another ally in Texcoco, and that's very important as well in taking control of the lake. And again, that's often lost, not just in the Spaniards' own accounts, but in later romantic versions of the story, the William Prescott in the 19th century or something, where it's seen as Spaniards' own accounts. But in later kind of romantic versions of the story, the kind of William Prescott in the 19th century or something, where it's seen as Spaniards versus
我完全同意你。我只是想说这个。在科尔特斯的信件等等中，他淡化了特拉斯卡拉人的参与。是的，他不想提那个。所以不仅是特拉斯卡拉，后来他们还会在特斯科科有另一个盟友，这对控制湖泊也非常重要。同样，这一点经常被遗忘，不仅是在西班牙人自己的记载中，而且在后来浪漫化的故事版本中，比如19世纪的威廉·普雷斯科特之类的，在那里它被视为西班牙人与
Aztecs, it was never like that. Spaniards were always outnumbered by their indigenous allies. But more Spaniards are starting to arrive, aren't they? Yes. So in late 1520 now, and there are ships arriving from Cuba, Hispaniola, or even from Spain all the time. And they're bringing supplies of guns and crossbows and horses, but above all, they are bringing more and more people. And so what is Cortes' status vis-a-vis Velázquez and Charles V back in Spain now? This is still very uncertain. Nothing has legally been settled. So Cortes is actually pursuing this enterprise without any form really of legal sanction. He's got the stuff about the
阿兹特克人之间的对抗，从来都不是那样的。西班牙人的人数总是少于他们的土著盟友。但更多的西班牙人开始到达了，不是吗？是的。现在是1520年底，来自古巴、伊斯帕尼奥拉甚至西班牙的船只一直在到达。他们带来了枪支、弩和马匹的补给，但最重要的是，他们带来了越来越多的人。那么科尔特斯相对于回到西班牙的委拉斯开兹和查理五世现在的地位如何？这仍然非常不确定。没有任何法律上的定论。所以科尔特斯实际上是在没有任何形式的法律制裁的情况下进行这项事业。他有关于
town. I've just been appointed by the town council of Vera Cruz. That was his claim. But he doesn't have any letter from the king saying, you are the governor, you are the viceroy, anything like that. So the people who are coming, these are- Glory hunters. Yeah, glory hunters, entrepreneurial fighters. But but presumably i mean you know wisdom of the crowds they think yeah we're onto a good thing here they do we can make money now a key part of this story if we just move for thousands of miles east charles v the great king of spain but also the emperor ruler of huge swathes of Europe, is in the Low Countries, proceeding around. And with him, he has brought the gold that Cortes originally sent back. And his men
城镇的事情。我刚刚被维拉克鲁斯市议会任命。那是他的主张。但他没有任何来自国王的信说，你是总督，你是副王，诸如此类的东西。所以那些来的人，这些人是——荣耀猎人。是的，荣耀猎人，投机取巧的战士。但是，我想，你知道，群众的智慧，他们认为“是的，我们在这里发现了一个好东西”。他们确实可以赚钱。现在，如果我们向东移动几千英里，这个故事的一个关键部分是，西班牙伟大的国王查理五世，同时也是欧洲大片土地的皇帝统治者，正在低地国家巡视。他随身带来了科尔特斯最初送回的黄金。他的人
have put it on as an exhibition in Brussels Town Hall, magnificent, late medieval Renaissance building. On the 27th of August, 1520- Oh, this is Albrecht Durer. A young man called Albrecht Durer goes to see it. And he's blown away, isn't he? Yeah, an extraordinary account. I saw the things which had been brought to the king from the new land of gold. I saw a sun all of gold, a whole fathom broad, a moon all of silver of the same size, two rooms of armour, and all manner of wondrous weapons,
把它放在布鲁塞尔市政厅展出，那是一座宏伟的晚期中世纪文艺复兴建筑。1520年8月27日——哦，这是阿尔布雷希特·丢勒。一个叫阿尔布雷希特·丢勒的年轻人去看了。他被震撼了，不是吗？是的，一份非凡的记录。我看到了从黄金新大陆带给国王的东西。我看到了一个纯金的太阳，整整一英寻宽，一个同样大小的纯银月亮，两间盔甲室，以及各种各样的奇妙武器，
very strange clothing and all kinds of wonderful objects. All the days of my life I have seen nothing that rejoiced my heart so much as these things, for I saw among them wonderful works of art, and I marveled at the subtle ingenuity of men in foreign lands. I mean, I wonder about that word ingenuity. I wonder if it's coming from ingenio. It is. It is. Yes. Which would perhaps more properly be described as genius. So the genius of a people. Yes. It's often left in the original. I think ingenuity downplays it. I think it's recognising this is amazing.
非常奇怪的服装和各种各样的奇妙物品。我一生中从未见过什么东西像这些东西一样让我心花怒放，因为我在其中看到了奇妙的艺术品，我惊叹于外国人的微妙智慧（ingenuity）。我的意思是，我很好奇“智慧”这个词。我想知道它是否来自“ingenio”。确实是。是的。这也许更恰当地被描述为天才。所以是一个民族的天才。是的。它经常保留在原文中。我认为“智慧”淡化了它。我认为这是在承认这太令人惊叹了。
Yeah. I mean, it's not just that they're ingenious. They have a distinctive quality that we would never have guessed. I think you're absolutely right, Tom. I think Jura is completely blown away by it. I think most people in Europe are stunned and staggered. I think it gives the lie, actually, that passage, the idea that people in Europe immediately saw the peoples of the New World as backwards and as lesser,
是的。我的意思是，不仅仅是他们聪明。他们有一种我们永远无法猜到的独特品质。我想你是完全正确的，汤姆。我认为丢勒完全被它震撼了。我认为欧洲的大多数人都感到震惊和惊愕。我认为那段话实际上揭穿了那种认为欧洲人立即将新大陆人民视为落后和低人一等的想法，
because Jura certainly doesn't. I think they had done, hadn't they, with the Tainos? Yeah. I think the general feeling of disappointment. Yes. But the revelation of these treasures and then the reports coming back saying it's better than Venice, I guess that is changing. Definitely it is. So this is a qualitative difference from the stuff that was coming
因为丢勒肯定没有这样看。我想他们之前确实是这样看的，不是吗，对泰诺人？是的。我想普遍的感觉是失望。是的。但这些宝藏的揭示，以及随后传回的报告说它比威尼斯还要好，我想这正在改变。绝对是这样。所以这与1490年代传回的东西有质的区别。
back in the 1490s. This blows people's minds. It's like you've discovered an alien civilization and it's not some sort of Beatles kind of messing around in rock formations. Yeah, blobs of amoeba. This is a glittering city. And of course, when people see this and the word spreads, people are printing reports of it and writing letters to each other, very excited. Of course, loads of people are going to pile in. Hundreds and then thousands. Isn't there also, there's a report that appears, so this is the first illustration of Tenochtitlan in any European source. I think it's published in Nuremberg. Yeah, Nuremberg. Yeah. And it's part of a newsletter that is set out by the bankers in
这让人们大开眼界。就像你发现了一个外星文明，而不是某种在岩层中乱搞的甲壳虫。是的，变形虫的斑点。这是一座闪闪发光的城市。当然，当人们看到这一点，消息传开时，人们在印刷关于它的报告并互相写信，非常兴奋。当然，很多人会蜂拥而至。成百上千，然后成千上万。难道没有一份报告出现吗？这是任何欧洲来源中对特诺奇蒂特兰的第一幅插图。我想它是在纽伦堡出版的。是的，纽伦堡。是的。它是纽伦堡的银行家们发出的通讯的一部分。
Nuremberg. So they are obviously immediately waking up. It's probably not the artistic quality of the metal work that's appealing to them, but the fact that it glitters. Of course. So they know what is out there. And so all of which presumably is fueling enthusiasm, not just in the West Indies, but in Europe for people to go out there. Absolutely, Tom. And they're going to bring those two things for which the indigenous peoples are completely
所以他们显然立即醒悟了。吸引他们的可能不是金属制品的艺术质量，而是它闪闪发光的事实。当然。所以他们知道外面有什么。所有这些大概都在助长热情，不仅是在西印度群岛，而且在欧洲，让人们去那里。绝对是，汤姆。他们将带来那两样东西，而土著人民对此完全
unrepaired. One of them is the weaponry. So the swords, the guns, all that business. A cannon. And they're going to bring germs and more viruses that will cause enormous damage to the peoples of the Americas. So let's get to Christmas 1520, end of the year. Cortes spends the winter back in Tlaxcala. He's already started to knock out some of the towns and cities that are loyal to Tenochtitlan. We're not obviously going to go through them all. He has cut most of Tenochtitlan's links to the coast,
毫无准备。其中之一是武器。所以剑、枪，所有这些东西。大炮。他们将带来细菌和更多的病毒，这将对美洲人民造成巨大的破坏。那么让我们谈谈1520年的圣诞节，年底。科尔特斯在特拉斯卡拉度过了冬天。他已经开始摧毁一些忠于特诺奇蒂特兰的城镇和城市。我们显然不会一一列举。他已经切断了特诺奇蒂特兰通往海岸的大部分联系，
and his plan is very clear. He will strangle the heartland of the Mexica, of the Aztec empire. He will confine them to the lake. He will win control of the lake towns. He will cut off their supplies of food and water. This is completely different from the campaigns that the Aztecs are used to fighting. They're used to those flower wars, these ritualized, almost, they're kind of sacral, aren't they, Tom? People dressing up as owls. Yes. Something about that. Yeah, we'll be coming back to people dressing up as owls later on.
他的计划非常明确。他将扼杀墨西加人、阿兹特克帝国的中心地带。他将把他们限制在湖中。他将赢得对湖边城镇的控制。他将切断他们的食物和水供应。这与阿兹特克人习惯的战争完全不同。他们习惯了那些“花之战”，这些仪式化的，几乎是神圣的，不是吗，汤姆？人们打扮成猫头鹰。是的。关于那个。是的，我们稍后会回到人们打扮成猫头鹰的话题。
I love an episode that features someone dressing up as an owl. So they are used to these campaigns where you take prisoners for sacrifice, not where you starve people out and you fight over months and months of very long campaign, a European style campaign, a war of attrition. And this is Cortez's plan. Slash Garland's are kind of happy to go along with it. They have their own internal issues because of course, they've got smallpox. They have some faction fighting, but basically they go along with him. The story goes that on the 27th of December, Cortes prepares to go for phase two. He gathers his men in the main temple in Tlaxcala. And he says, as you would expect, he would, he says, this is a great crusade. We're going to win Mexico for Christ and so on. And then a rare
我喜欢那种有打扮成猫头鹰的人出现的剧集。所以他们习惯了那些为了祭祀而抓俘虏的战役，而不是那种让你饿死，为了几个月又几个月的漫长战役而战斗的战役，一种欧洲式的战役，一场消耗战。这就是科尔特斯的计划。特拉斯卡拉人很高兴随行。他们有自己的内部问题，因为当然，他们有天花。他们有一些派系斗争，但基本上他们跟随他。故事说，12月27日，科尔特斯准备进行第二阶段。他在特拉斯卡拉的主神庙召集了他的手下。他说，正如你所预料的那样，他说，这是一场伟大的十字军东征。我们要为基督赢得墨西哥等等。然后是一个罕见的
moment of honesty. He says, it just so happens that this campaign will bring us both honor and profit, two things that very rarely go together. Yeah. Well, that's Cortez. To in a nutshell, isn't it? So on New Year's Eve, they hit the town of Texcoco, which is the second city of the Aztec Triple Alliance. There's a whole issue with a massive succession crisis that's been going on in Texcoco. Don't go there, Dominic. Yeah, I'm not going to go there.
诚实时刻。他说，恰好这场战役将带给我们荣誉和利润，这两样东西很少能同时得到。是的。嗯，这就是科尔特斯，简而言之，不是吗？所以在除夕夜，他们袭击了特斯科科镇，这是阿兹特克三方同盟的第二大城市。特斯科科发生了一场巨大的继承危机。别去那里，多米尼克。是的，我不会去那里。
I actually find it very hard to follow. It's a very beautiful city. It's an artistic center. It's a crucial breadbasket for the Aztecs. And Cortes takes it amid scenes of extreme violence. He sacks the city, they loot and burn. It was famous for its beautifully decorated maps and books. They're all burned.
我实际上发现很难跟上。那是一座非常美丽的城市。它是一个艺术中心。它是阿兹特克人的关键粮仓。科尔特斯在极度暴力的场景中占领了它。他洗劫了这座城市，他们抢劫并焚烧。它以其装饰精美的地图和书籍而闻名。它们都被烧毁了。
So these fantastic sources that might have shed so much light on this story are destroyed. It's on the lake, so it's a key naval base. Right, and that shipwright who has survived, presumably, is still with Cortes. Martin Lopez. He is back in Tlaxcala and he is building a fleet. Not a massive fleet, 12 ships, brigantines. But enough.
所以这些可能为这个故事提供了如此多线索的奇妙来源被摧毁了。它在湖上，所以它是一个关键的海军基地。没错，那个幸存下来的造船匠，大概还在科尔特斯身边。马丁·洛佩斯。他回到了特拉斯卡拉，他正在建造一支舰队。不是一支庞大的舰队，12艘船，双桅横帆船。但足够了。
But enough. Just before he makes the ships, Cortés is moving around the lake, taking town after town. One town we will mention. It's a town called Iztapalapan. And it's that town that if you've been listening to this whole series, you will remember. The Spaniards arrived there before they first met Montezuma. And Bernal Diaz talked about how beautiful it was, the gardens with the channels where you could canoe down to the lake, the beautiful mansions. And he said, it's like something from a romance. It's like something from amadis this chivalric romance and bernal diaz said how sad it was to remember it because not a stone is left standing
但足够了。就在他制造这些船之前，科尔特斯正在湖周围移动，一个接一个地占领城镇。我们将提到的一个城镇。它叫伊斯塔帕拉潘。如果你一直在听这个系列节目，你会记得那个城镇。西班牙人在第一次见到蒙特祖马之前就到达了那里。贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯谈到了它是多么美丽，有可以划独木舟到湖里的水道的花园，美丽的豪宅。他说，这就像浪漫小说里的东西。这就像阿马迪斯（Amadis）这种骑士浪漫小说里的东西，贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说，想起它真是太难过了，因为连一块石头都没剩下。
the reason not a stone is left standing is what cortez does now he and his men go in and they destroy the town they absolutely destroy it and they send a message around the lake if you don't back us if you don't give in straight away, we will utterly destroy you. Very Mongol behavior. Very Mongol. And town after town around the lake surrenders, throws their lot in with the Tlaxcalans and the Spaniards. And then in late February,
连一块石头都没剩下的原因是科尔特斯现在所做的。他和他的手下进去，摧毁了这座城镇，他们彻底摧毁了它，并向湖周围传达了一个信息：如果你不支持我们，如果你不立即投降，我们将彻底摧毁你。非常蒙古式的行为。非常蒙古。湖周围一个接一个的城镇投降，与特拉斯卡拉人和西班牙人站在了一起。然后在2月底，
Martin Lopez, who's been back making these ships, the guy who had survived the Notte Trees and gladdened Cortez's heart, he finally arrives in Texcoco on the lakeshore with 12 ships being carried overland by hundreds of Tlaxcalan porters. And when he pitches up, Cortes now has the fleet that he needs to begin the final assault on the great city of Tenochtitlan. And that will be the theme of our next episode, which you can either hear in due course, or you can hear straight away simply by joining
马丁·洛佩斯，那个回到这里制造这些船的人，那个在“悲伤之夜”中幸存下来并让科尔特斯心花怒放的人，他终于带着12艘船到达了湖岸的特斯科科，这些船是由数百名特拉斯卡拉搬运工陆路运送的。当他到达时，科尔特斯现在拥有了开始对特诺奇蒂特兰大城市进行最后突击所需的舰队。这将是我们下一集的主题，你可以在适当的时候听到，或者你可以通过加入
the Restless History Club. People will never tire of you saying that, Tom. Do you know, I feel bad about saying it because, you know, the past half hour has been so grim. I mean, this is effectively the destruction of an extraordinary civilization. I do feel a bit bad about using it to monetize, but whatever. The spirit of the European greed burns strong within me. If it makes you feel better, I don't think the Aztec civilization was totally destroyed. And we'll discuss this in the final episode. Okay. All right. I'll rephrase that. The cities that had impressed even the conquistadors as the most exquisite cityscapes that they had ever seen in the process of being
“Restless History Club”立即听到。人们永远不会厌倦你说这句话，汤姆。你知道，我因为说这句话而感到难过，因为，你知道，过去半小时太沉重了。我的意思是，这实际上是一个非凡文明的毁灭。我确实因为用它来赚钱而感到有点难过，但无论如何。欧洲贪婪的精神在我心中燃烧得很强烈。如果这让你感觉好点，我不认为阿兹特克文明被完全摧毁了。我们将在最后一集中讨论这个问题。好吧。好吧。我会重新措辞。那些甚至让征服者都印象深刻的、他们所见过的最精致的城市景观，正在被
obliterated. And Tenochtitlan itself is now in the firing line. So anyway, I just feel a bit bad about it, but not that bad. I'm still flogging it. They were entrepreneurial in their own way, the Aztecs. Yeah. Well, they were going out and conquering people and all that malarkey. They're listening to this podcast. They would say at the end, as Theo always does, tell them about the club. What about the club?
抹去。而特诺奇蒂特兰本身现在正处于火线上。所以，总之，我只是对此感到有点难过，但没那么难过。我还在兜售它。阿兹特克人有他们自己的创业精神。是的。嗯，他们出去征服别人等等。他们正在听这个播客。他们会在最后说，正如西奥总是做的那样，告诉他们关于俱乐部的事。俱乐部怎么样？
Wouldn't they? Yeah. It's what Wistipochli would want. It is exactly. It's our own version of the Triple Alliance. That's what it is. Right. On that bombshell, we'll see you all next time for the Siege of Tenochtitlan.
他们会吗？是的。这是维齐洛波奇特利（Witzilopochtli）想要的。正是如此。这是我们自己版本的三方同盟。就是这样。好吧。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次再见，去讲特诺奇蒂特兰围城战。
Goodbye. See you then. Bye-bye. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。到时候见。再见。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。